[Music]
hi welcome to the what's new in
kubernetes run buff and high performance
Computing on gke session
my name is Magic rajatski I'm a product
manager at Google and I will be joined
by Louis bayell Chief Enterprise
architect at pgs
we will give you first a deep dive into
what are the best practices and what are
the latest features available for you to
use in kubernetes and the gke for upper
running back and high performance
Computing workloads and then Louis will
take over and will cover how pgs has
built the high performance Computing
platform on GK and gcp
first let's align on the terminology and
what class of oracles are we actually
going to talk about today
what are batch workloads and these are
workloads that run to completion they
have a start and end and usually you run
offline without access to end users they
are flexible either on time location or
potentially they can tolerate disruption
and they are very diverse they range
from scientific workloads machine
learning training or these might be TL
jobs that are part of your data
analytics platform despite that
diversity there is a set of fundamental
settings and options that you need to
take a close look at when designing and
building QR infrastructure that will
host your batch workloads uh first and
foremost you need a lot of competing
power to execute them uh gke for the
last two years has been the managed
kubernetes provider that supports the
largest single cluster size with 15 000
nodes by cluster it's particularly
important
um because uh in this class of workloads
we see a pattern that users prefer to
run on solar VMS than they used to own
on-premises they even go up to the point
where they run a single up to two worker
pods containers per single VM that
simplifies the development process helps
avoid Noisy Neighbor problems have been
packing but still we need the same level
of computing power in terms of CPU so
that naturally increases the cluster
size when it comes to throughput GK
supports 100 points a second when it
comes to Peak throughput and 30 to 50
pods a second as throughput for a longer
term average it depends also on what are
the specific activities that you're
performing in the cluster Beyond uh pod
scheduling
if you have large container images for
example you may have some data back into
container images or like in machine
learning use cases we frequently see
significant portfolio of libraries baked
into images and they may go even above
10 gigabytes in terms of size UK has a
very important feature called image
streaming that allows you to start a
container without having it fully
downloaded which in this case has
greatly improved end-to-end performance
and execution of the entire workload
now aside from performance second most
important aspect if not equally
important is the cost of your
infrastructure the most popular feature
that I that is leveraged to optimize
costs of batch workloads are small VMS
these are VMS that are used to sell the
excess capacity that we maintain as a
buffer inside our data centers and they
come with the risk that the VM might be
disrupted with preemption or there may
be periods when they are not available
but they come with very significant
discounts they vary between machine
types and locations but they go up to 99
if your workload can either be pointed
or easily restarted it will be a perfect
fit for running on spot VMS gke comes
with a plethora of features and
capabilities to smoothen the experience
of running on those VMS it automatically
uses them if you build a cluster that
mixes various BN types and shapes it
will be able to make conscious choices
which VMS to provision so that your cost
is optimized and adapt if there are any
availability or obtainability challenges
associated with odd VMS and even be able
to fail over the on-demand instances if
temporarily spot VMS are not available
aside from using Sports VMS there are a
few important settings in the cluster
that will also help you optimize the
cost first one is no doubt provisioning
so a model for cluster plus scalar where
it will automatically decide and create
the right VM shapes for your workload
this feature actually shows that if it's
enabled clusters that have it enabled in
our Fleet have the best level of beam
packing in our Fleet a second important
feature is the use of Auto scaling
profiles optimize utilization adjusts
your auto scaling and scheduling
Behavior so that it further boosts the
bin packing level inside your cluster
and in original clusters it's important
that you use any spreading policy it was
recently launched and it allows you to
make the cluster follow either available
capacity or available reservations which
will be a perfect fit for use cases with
either spot VMS or reserved instances or
reserved resources like for example you
may have gpus reserved
now if you would like to avoid the
hassle of making sure that you have all
of the configuration options right for
your cluster then you recommend that you
use gke in autopilot mode it is a mode
of operations for our clusters where you
give up some of the control and some of
the configuration options for the
cluster and it comes with a different
pricing model but Google takes over a
lot of the responsibility associated
with running your cluster and this leads
to more effective operations for your
engineering teams and also in many cases
lower costs when it comes to compute
costs we recently launched two important
features oriented on batch workloads so
compute classes and GPU support
now on workload level it's important
that you try to stick to core kubernetes
features as much as possible kubernetes
allows you to replay its components as
you see fit and GK will support that for
most components but if you stick to
color especially job API scheduler and
cluster autoscaler you will be able to
get the benefits of their very tight
integration with our underlying stack in
our cloud and also you will greatly
simplify any integration work with the
broad ecosystem of tools that are
available in the open source Community
for kubernetes
now when it comes to job queuing which
is a very important capability needed in
bad processing systems we recently
launched q.sh our queuing operator that
is very slim in its implementation it
does not replace any core components of
kubernetes so it makes integration with
any tools very easy queuing is of course
very important in on-premises
environments where you have limited
resources and you would like to run a
significant backlog of jobs and
consciously decide which ones will be
executed when but also in Cloud
environments you may be running against
certain constraints for example you want
to make sure that you fully utilize your
comment that use discounted instances or
some reserved instances or you may have
some other constraint that you would
like to enforce in the infrastructure
and then consciously decide through
policies which workloads get executed
well
last but not least I would like to cover
recommendations for tightly coupled
workloads that need to communicate very
extensively between one another in here
we have the most important feature is to
use compact placement which is currently
in preview which will allow you to
create VMS in close proximity to each
other within our data centers there is
also a set of other kernel configuration
settings that you should use in this
context that will allow you to optimize
Network performance or CPU performance
be sure to check their documentation
before changing them as they will change
the behavior of your cluster or your
workloads
and for orchestration of workloads like
MPI jobs we recommend coupon operator
version too that recently our Engineers
have worked on to optimize for
scalability and performance and with
that I would like to pass the voice to
Louis who will give you a deep dive into
how pgs is using all of these features
to run their high performance Computing
platform
thanks nashik I'm rebayal I'm Chief
Enterprise architect for pgs and will
explain how pgs has made gke into a
supercomputer
but first what is videos we are an
integrated Marine geophysical company
which means that we acquire seismic data
from the Australian subsurface and
process it into images of the subsurface
layers
this is mostly used for offshore
renewable carbon capture and ordering
gas
the data volume that we process can be
multiple of petabytes this is mostly
because the survey we acquire can be
hundreds or thousands of square
kilometers and the mass that are needed
in order to process the data into images
require extreme amount of compute power
historically in order to achieve this we
were using supercomputers mostly create
xc40 and accessories in June 2015 when
we introduced Apple we ranked 12s on the
top 500 supercomputers lists that's what
with 5.37 petaflops and almost 150 000
cores we added another little browser
basically to Able which is Galloway
which was 2.1 petaflops bringing the
total to almost 200 or more than 200 000
cores that is a lot of compute but for
the data we needed to a lot of storage
too and we added 12 terabytes of luster
file system which is a highly
specialized power system for
supercomputers and we had the ability to
use up to 257 gigabytes second of
throughput so a lot of computing a lot
of storage
um but we always need more and how do I
age quite a bit and easily so around
2018 2019 when the time was to start
thinking about renewing the platform we
wonder what we would do
end of the time the idea was to start to
use the on-premise for the maximum
average utilization and use the cloud
for all the spike in the burst basically
so the idea was to move into gcp for 20
for total compute and stay on premise
for the 80 with maximum average
utilization possible the idea at the
time was to do a lift and shift and
basically takes whatever was running on
premise moving into gcp and run it that
way
but the thing is 2020 came and changed a
lot of plans especially for us the
economic downturn causes a lot of
financial trouble so renewing the
on-premise was not no longer possible
due to the heavy capex investment So
based on the successes that we had from
the early prototype and PLC that we did
in gcp we revised our ambition and
decided that instead of renewing on
premise we would actually move the
workload into the cloud
this changes the strategy also from a
lift and chief to move and improve our
technically on full re-engineering
because the lifting Chief was kind of
efficient and cost efficient at small
scale but will not be efficient for for
the scale we were going for
but we did and by May 2022 we actually
this decommissioned the last creative
supercomputer and we had 80 of all
compute that we are running in gcp
so how did we do it we turned gke into a
supercomputer
and in order to do this we actually had
to use a lot of the key we actually have
the ability to use up to 12 DK cluster
up to their maximum capacity of 15 000
instances and the ability to use GCS for
the storage we had to convert to GCS
because there was no way we could run a
luster or any parallel fire system
address scale we needed at a
constipation price point
but we also needed to do another
engineering effort which was to move
from standard notes to split VMS or
preemptible for cost efficiency this
this was significant but at the end we
were able to reach very very significant
numbers the peak that we have preached
now on numerous instances 53 000 which
account for about 21 petaflops that
would put us to the top 24 the current
list of supercomputers on the GCS side
we've been able to reach 500 gigabytes a
second which is very significant for us
in details what we actually had to build
is
a lot but it can boil down into having
to bridge the on-premises environment
and the existing workflow on premise
with what is happening in gcp and GK in
particular mostly we had to build
services to transfer data from the Lost
part system on premise into GCS using a
40 gig in technique between all premises
and using floor 1. we also had to build
a handful of services that magically
bridge the gap between the cloud and the
existing workflow for the user
on-premise mostly how all the users are
submitting job and how they are
retrieving statuses and logs from the
job running in gke
within GK we Leverage is not pools in
order to run all the workloads and we're
mostly using preemptible in order to
reduce our average cost but we also have
the ability to use on-demand nodes in
order to run a part of jobs that to
control for a non-premise work it can be
printed
we also use GCS in order to store
checkpoints for the for the VMS to that
are preempted
inside gke we actually only leveraging
standard component we it's all the
things that you find in any kubernetes
cluster like we're using services for
the job manager that is dispatching
kubernetes that's job and we're still
using a service for radius in order to
store progress and statuses of different
jobs the workload run as part that are
pinned to instances using labels and the
GK autoscaler provision node on demand
based on whatever is being submitted on
the cluster
we have a handful of services outside
gke that hello to spread the workload
across multiple GK cluster and also
dries number of the creation and
deletion of node pools based on what the
workloads require in terms of instance
type and numbers
this allows us to reach or goal which
was to limit significantly the capex
investment for the renewal of our
on-premise platform but also yielded a
lot of interesting side effects for
example when we buy on premise a new
platform we are stuck with it for a long
time between five to ten years most of
the time in the cloud we have very big
Hardware flexibility we are able to
choose CPU and memory based on each
workload instead of being stuck on the
same platform it was also a very good
opportunity for modernization the
on-premise design was basically 10 to 15
years ago and needed quite a bit of
changes the ability to move to
microservice and kubernetes was very
good for like bringing some pressure
into our ecosystem
last but not least moving into gcp was a
good way for us to offset our carbon
footprint The Craze supercomputers were
concerning about three megawatts of
power and moving into U.S Central 1
which has 97 Carbon free energy is a
really good step in the right direction
to summarize our numbers we've been
already today able to reach very
significant milestone in terms of
increase of power from on-premise to gcp
the number of core users we are already
2x for petaflops between the generation
gap and the acquaintance of corals we
already almost 3x for the storage
element that we can consume we already
6X and for the bandwidths almost 2X and
we know we can climb higher we just
haven't had the opportunity yet
and I will leave you with a pretty graph
of one of the latest achievement where
we've been able to scale up to 53 000
instances for a job that would have
taken weeks on premise this is a
significant reduction in turn around
because we could run this in days
and with that I will conclude and on
back to meshek
thank you Louis and thank you everyone
for watching our session we hope you
really enjoyed it and we hope you will
enjoy next 22.
[Music]